oh it's awful
um and it was hugely surprising
to hear those personal details uh about
Nicola bully revealed uh in the way that
they were
um I think that all of us are praying
and hoping that she's out there you want
to have a call out for her to return to
her family
notwithstanding what's been said about
her and my heart goes out to her
daughters particularly who must be
hugely hugely distressed not having
their Mummy at home
yeah we spoke to Yvette Cooper actually
yesterday she wanted some answers from
Lancashire police about the information
that they had released about her
your view on that
I it's unclear to me why this
information was pertinent and important
to the investigation and how it leads to
her return
um and so like so many members of the
public I'm surprised that this has
happened in this way the important thing
now
um is that she's found
um and that she's returned to her family
talk to me um about the boss going to uh
Kiev yesterday what was all that about
well look I think it is important
to
underlie very very clearly the cross
party support for the Ukrainian people
at this time particularly as they
prepare for what looks like a spring
offensive and more aggression from Putin
and his troops and his forces here in
the United Kingdom the labor party the
conservatives all of the opposition has
stood shoulder to shoulder with the
people of Ukraine to support them
militarily uh politically diplomatically
and economically at this very very
difficult time and I'm here in Munich as
the global Community gathers and number
one on the agenda is to ensure that the
ukrainians Prevail and that we assist
them in that effort
but isn't that the prime minister's job
rather than the leader of the opposition
oh look I mean just as it was right for
kirstama to go to Northern Ireland a few
weeks ago to be in Davos
um a few weeks ago of course it's right
that in the biggest foreign policy
challenge of our time that he's meeting
uh zelenski for the second time and
being absolutely clear that if there was
to be a change of government and we
would expect the next the next election
at some point next year that that
support for Ukraine would continue and
I'm pleased that um zielinski indicated
that he's very grateful for that
uh you bring up Northern Ireland um
Shadow foreign Secretary of course
that's where the prime minister is going
to be today to try and sort out these
challenges still surrounding brexit I
hear that labor say that they will be
supporting the government
um I wonder if there are any Riders uh
in relation
um to that what is it that you're
actually supporting them in
okay you will recall that the
significant issue facing Rishi sunac is
in fact with his own benches and the ERG
particularly uh who have found a big
issue with the European court of justice
as the final Court of dispute that would
deal with the issues that might arise as
a result of differences over those
Customs check we have been very clear
and clear set this out a few weeks ago
when he was in Northern Ireland
um that we will support the government
to get uh this through to take this off
the table and the reason we'll do that
because we believe that it's in the
interests of Northern Ireland all
communities in Northern Ireland that
they now have certainty in relation to
these issues and that we can move
forward and so for that reason if he
needs the votes from labor we will
support it
um okay so that there aren't any Riders
there if they go ahead with what has
already been discussed they've got your
complete backing they do have our
backing uh we're clear on that
okay talk to me about why you're in
Munich today
well look I think that there are three
issues facing the global community that
uh that we gather for one of course is
Ukraine that we've discussed the second
is China these spy balloons aggression
in the Taiwan Straits and the third is
Iran and their desire for nuclear
capability over this next period so this
is a dangerous moment I'm here to bring
the message that we believe that the
United Kingdom has to be reconnected in
the global Community reconnected with
our allies to deal with these big issues
to bring that message about how a labor
government would approach these issues
to meet with world leaders but to
underline and to speak about the
challenges that are facing not just our
own economy but many economies across
the globe because all foreign policy at
this time
um is domestic when we see the fights on
energy the fights on climate uh
migration all foreign policy comes back
to domestic policy and the security and
prosperity over people in the United
Kingdom